let's bring in Newt Gingrich he's
foxnews contributor former Speaker of
the House he joins us from Rome actually
mr. speaker I'm sure you can understand
how here in the United States right now
there's a lot of frustration a lot of
people want to get back to work but
there are a lot of these stay-at-home
orders for a variety of reasons so that
the curb goes down and people can
eventually go back to work and and all
of the social distancing eventually goes
away but can you understand the
frustration for the people who are in
Montana versus the people who might be
here in New Jersey because you're in a
hot spot you were in Rome sure I've
looked the virus not to be so bad in
Italy that they had no choice except to
close virtually everything and it's been
pretty strict now for about six or seven
weeks yeah if you leave your house you
can't go more than 200 meters even to
walk your dog or whatever you can't be
in groups of larger than two you can be
fined $3,200 if the police find you on
the street without an appropriate reason
they have gas stations open pharmacies
grocery stores that's it now for 17
straight days they've had a steady slow
decline in the number of people going
into intensive care units and it is
beginning to be some optimism that we
are very very close to reaching a
plateau and starting down low I think
they're beginning to inch towards
opening a few things here it tells us a
lot about Italy one of the first things
they're going to reopen are stores that
fix coffee machines he goes without
expresso and other Italian coffees
how can one truly live so I thought that
was a perfectly Italian solution but
they're being very careful very slow and
I would say there are two things going
on first of all the United States is a
gigantic country it's bigger than all of
Europe and so what's right for Montana
or Texas or what's right for West Texas
versus Houston are different things I
think the president's very wise to
decentralize delegate and give the
governor's in the Sun second I think
some of the governor's have shown their
ideal
bias so that one governor for example
said it was okay for Planned Parenthood
to stay open for abortions but it wasn't
okay for the churches to end services
well that's clearly just an ideological
abuse of the emergency and I think that
part of what has people with their teeth
on edge because they're watching
politicians abused their power so I
think the president's right go back to
work slowly carefully learn lessons I
mean if South Dakota and North Dakota
for example working with Sanford Health
and others decides that they're going to
gradually open up let's learn from what
works and what doesn't work and every
state should study every other state as
they go through this process in a couple
months I think we'll be dramatically
further down the road I know that you
address many of these issues in your
op-ed on foxnews.com the the headline is
coronavirus crisis make some leaders
believe that they have godlike
decision-making capacity will you
explain that which leaders are you
talking about well one is the governor
of Michigan who issued this this truly
absurd executive order suggesting for
example that you couldn't buy a child's
seat
you couldn't buy a seed so if you went
to Walmart or you went to Home Depot the
area that sow seeds to plant in your
backyard had a sign up that said it's
illegal to buy these right now well I
mean normal people thought what is that
all about and you look at the list for
you well you sort of get is it so you
know in turn must've written it up
because it makes so little sense and I
think that's an example you had a mayor
in Illinois who declared that she had
the right to decide who couldn't get
food I mean the kind of things you know
Lord Acton warned us that power tends to
corrupt and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and you look around the
country one of the major
responsibilities right after defeating
the virus and restarting the economy the
third big efforts going to be take power
back from the politicians because you
cannot allow them to decide that their
little little petty gods
who gets it in fact life and death for
all the Reston's yeah that Democratic
governor might be doing her her work
might be doing her best to get Donald
Trump Michigan again we'll have to see
I saw the New York Times do a story on
her and then even bring up the fifty-two
executive orders like don't buy paint
you can't use a motorboat but you can
use a kayak they'd even put that in the
story or that for sheriff said we're not
going to enforce this meanwhile your
Idol Nancy Pelosi was the job that used
to have weighed in on what kind of job
Donald Trump's doing and to the surprise
of um nobody not very good according to
her
listen don't you believe doctor foul
chief yo he said if this were to drown
properly well it hasn't been done on
March fourth we passed our first bill
bipartisan testing testing testing it's
over six weeks since and it hasn't been
done we're way late on it and that is
the failure the president gets an F a
failure on the testing but the factor
foul she's right if it is done properly
it hasn't been and that I think we buddy
puts it in the if it's done is an
admission that it hasn't been done
she sat there by her love multi-million
dollar refrigerators and made those
comments your your response well I wrote
I wrote my newsletter Friday on on the
job-killing ice cream eating Democrats
because I thought the whole notion of
Nancy Pelosi holding up aid to small
business while she stood have brought
her two very expensive refrigerators and
talked about that she loves to have her
$11 and seventy five cent of plain ice
cream the comforts her and it's the most
tone-deaf thing I have ever seen a
Speaker of the House doing then I served
with Tip O'Neill and Jim Wright and Tom
Foley and of course they worked with
Denny Hastert and John Boehner and and
Paul Ryan this was just plain goofy I
mean even by San Francisco standards it
was goofy the fact is the president's
worked very closely with dr. pouchy and
dr. coxy says so every time he's asked
by the press he and dr. Burks both have
very professional standards
they've been advising the president but
in the end look the reason you have a
present is there are some decisions
larger than experts and it's the job of
the president to weigh everything and
then try to make the best possible
decision I would say overall you look at
our fatality rate and you look at Europe
and you can feel pretty good about what
the Trump administration has done Newt
I'm sure you saw some of the video of
the various protests around the country
regarding the stay at home orders in one
of the big ones was in Denver Colorado
yesterday and the Denver Post talked to
a fella by the name of Jim Fenimore and
he said that he thinks that Democrats
are using the coronavirus as a political
tool he said to crash the economy and
hurt the president so that he loses you
don't think there are politics like that
involved in these calculations do you I
don't to be honest I don't think that
Schumer and Pelosi mind or the Biden
Minds if the economy doesn't quite
recover rapidly I mean they're faced
with a nightmare if the president
finishes handling the coronavirus as
well as I think he will and you then
pivots and uses all of his ability to
create a strong economy and by September
in October you can tell that we're
coming back the election will be over
and Trump will get reelected well you
know if you're close in Schumer and
something sort of like to have that come
back say next January but not this
September and I I'm not saying that they
sit down and a coldly calculated way but
I don't think that they have at any
point placed putting America back to
work ahead of partisan politics and
that's why for a week now
they have screwed up the small business
loans which clearly hurts because small
business creates the largest number of
new jobs in America and you have a lot
of small businesses saying look I've got
about a week to go if I can't get
financing and they just said on it we
you tell me yeah why that is not frankly
a remarkably destructive thing we'll be
doing mr. speaker why did they do that
why the dumb why are they making us
why do the Democrats not pass the
proposal the last proposal I mean is it
because they don't want the president to
have a win
don't don't they need to put the
American people ahead of anything else
well I think that they are engaged in a
game of chicken and they've done this
now several times and there their hope
is at some point that the President or
Secretary of minuchin or somebody will
flinch and give them what they want and
I think that overall and I give senator
Mitch McConnell a great deal of credit
for this when he when he passed the very
large 2.2 trillion dollar aid package
and by 96 to 0 he took all the wind out
of Pelosi sales it was impossible for
her at that point to block anything but
what they're doing this search this is
not a game they want to say and then I
say the same thing when a speaker who
negotiated with a Democratic president
you know you can start up and you say
how far can i push him and of course
with Trump not very far and I think on
these issues they're so far out of sync
with the country that it's very
destructive for them to play these games
but I think that they have no choice
their left will not tolerate them
cooperating with Donald Trump gotcha all
right the other thing I want to bring it
to and before we get to what Jay Johnson
just told us as the Democratic Democrat
before he was former Secretary of
Homeland Security just from your
perspective you had a lot of European
countries about to get in bed with China
with this belt and road program and but
getting the 5g from Huawei after the
reality of how what they've done in
destroying 180 nation's economy and
killing so many from the irresponsible
behavior when it came to this virus do
you believe the Italians are rethinking
that Alliance and youthfully but beyond
Germany's already registered their
disdain
do you believe other countries are - yes
I think this has been a stunningly
eye-opening experience I have a paper
that will come out this week pointing
out based really on the Hudson
Institute's remarkable time landing they
produce a time line all the way back to
November of last year
and it's devastating the the University
of Southampton estimates that if the
Chinese have been
honest 95% of the people who have died
would still be alive now that is it
think about that over 160 thousand dead
and according to University of
Southampton 95 percent of people died
because the Chinese communist
dictatorship deliberately lied and got
its puppet at the World Health
Organization to deliberately lie and I
think frankly that we should take some
significant steps one which would affect
Italy which I would wrote about I
thought was brilliant he simply moved
the Winter Olympics of 2022 from China
back to Turin Italy which hosted it but
I think in 2002 and allow Turin at the
very center of the area that had been
savaged by the Chinese I'll turn to host
the Olympics next year that would be the
kind of gesture that would really begin
to communicate that the world sped up
with the way the dictatorship operates
and there's no question the Chinese
dictatorship has cost the world by the
time it's done though across the world
several hundred thousand lives and many
many trillions of dollars of economic
activity and something has to be done to
hold the dictatorship and Xi Jinping and
his in terribly accountable for the
damage they've done to the human race
worldwide well let's see what they
figure out mr. speaker thank you very
much for joining us from you stay safe
you bet